(upbeat music)
(Men laugh)
- Bro. I'm getting so nervous right now.
- Bro, what?
- Ladies first.
- Oh what the (beep).
Wait I'm not ready.
- All right I got one.
It's kind of sad and
depressing but I got one.
- That's our whole friendship.
- Sorry.
- It's okay.
- Do I introduce myself?
- [Woman] You can go ahead yeah.
- My name is Jay I'm
from Chicago, Illinois.
My deepest darkest secret is
(beep)
Oh I got one. I got one.
Yeah, matter of fact my
deepest darkest secret is--
Ah, this is going on internet.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Can we start that over?
- No, it's over with.
- Do you fart a lot?
- What?
- Because it's pretty annoying.
- No, you're lying.
- Just kidding.
- I was like what?
You're lying.
- No, one thing that annoys
me is you be eating my food
too many times and that's
been pissing me off
and use the bathroom any, so
you gotta, you gotta slow down.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- All right, come on, bro.
- No,  get the (bleep) outta here. You go first.
- No, what's your secret?
- I can't sleep without a nightlight.
- That's real dark.
- Okay. My secret is I
almost swiped left on you.
Then I ended up swiping
right and here we are.
- Oh, well it's good you swiped right.
- Yeah.
- Because that was the right thing to do.
She's throwing shade.
Well it's shady right now,
you don't see sun obviously.
- I'm not trying to throw shade.
And this is our first day
meeting in real life, so.
- 3D.
- 4D.
- 4D, yeah.
- Is this thing, is this thing on?
My name is Ron.
- Ron.
- I'm from Shreveport,
Louisiana, AKA ratchet city.
- Man.
- And my secret to you,
you know those Skittles you've been eating
for the past five days?
- Calm down, calm down.
- I found them in the trash.
I found them in the trash.
They were wet and everything.
- He ain't laughing but
we all ate them (bleep).
- Yeah.
- No cap, no cap.
- All right, who's next?
- I think I've told you everything.
I mean, you're secretly taller
than all the rest of my boyf-
You're the tallest.
- I don't know.
- But that's not a secret.
- I don't know, am I good?
Am I the best one in bed?
I don't know.
- Bro, this is PG.
- She's a little, she's the moderator.
She's a moderator.
- Yeah, bro.
- These are props.
- Yo, don't expose the props.
- [Woman] They are real,
what are you talking about?
- Yeah, they're fricking real man.
- Check, check.
- I secretly like you better
when your hair is gelled.
- I secretly like you
when you're not a douche.
(Woman laughs)
Okay?
Your dog knows that, your mom knows that.
- No, we've got to think
of better ones man.
- Okay.
- Hey, so my name is
uh, my name is Malcolm.
You know what I'm saying?
That's my first name.
I'm from the good old M-town.
Memphis, Tennessee.
You feel me?
So, my secret to you little bro,
is I was almost pissed off
whenever you uh bought the same shirt as me.
(men laugh)
- I almost cried.
- I almost cried, bro.
My brother got the same shirt as me.
I was just playing, but you know what I'm saying.
I know I'm (bleep) with you.
- When I was a kid I used to
drink milk in a baby bottle
all the way to sixth grade.
That's a big one.
(Woman laughs)
- Okay.
- I like it.
- I mean, it's a little weird.
I might have to take my
bottle away from my baby.
(Man and Woman laugh)
- I got one.
All right.
My name is Deontay.
They call me D.
- D.
- South Carolina.
- South.
- My secret is
my mom still read me bedtime stories, bro.
(Men laugh)
- That's the best way to sleep, baby.
That's the best way to sleep.
- Bro, what?
Bedtime stories, bro?
- Yeah, man.
- Bedtime stories, bro.
Oh my God.
Bro, you for real?
- For real.
(Men laugh)
- I think I feel the most loved by you
when you give me neck kisses.
- Oh, okay.
(Woman laughs)
Okay.
The best thing I like about you
is when you're very sweet around me.
- What does that mean?
- Even in public.
- Oh.
- Because you don't like PDA.
- Oh, okay.
That, yeah.
- Yeah, she does not like PDA people.
- Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I think that if we didn't
become friends, when we did
I probably would have
not been here, you know?
- Can I hug him now?
Oh come here.
I love you.
- I love you too.
- Okay.
Let's see.
I'm going to cook dinner for you tonight.
- Ooh.
That's not a surprise.
(Man and Woman laugh)
- I honestly love you beyond words.
We've had an interesting weekend and yeah.
I love you beyond words.
- What I want to tell you is
I love you more than anybody
I've ever loved before.
In this whole entire world.
My favorite person in the world.
- That's funny.
Because I've never been as happy
with anyone as I am with you.
You're perfect.
- I'm glad we are having a good time.
- I love you.
- So we've been through
so much stuff, like stuff
like stuff out of a movies and--
- We've kept each other out of jail.
(Men laughs)
- Pretty much.
There's a lot of opportunities
for us to go to jail,
but you know what?
We always look for each other
and he's always the guy I always rely on.
- [Woman] Tell him your secret.
- Oh okay.
- I never told him that
every day on my birthday
I always make a wish.
Always wish for the same thing.
When I met him,
that changed.
That wish now ended up being
instead of me being happy
is I hope the both of us be happy.
- [Woman] You and him?
- Shoot though.
I did not expect that.
Like I sure didn't expect that.
That was, that was really
out of character, I guess.
Yeah, if you will.
- Yeah.
- If you will.
Yeah.
Well actually I kinda told
you about this already but
I guess in light of being telling you.
So when we met,
like it was my first time out
of country alone, everything.
- Yeah.
- So, uh, you taking me out.
You showing me more about
Japan and everything like that.
Like that actually kind of like got me
out of my shell a bit,
but you have no idea
how much you contributed
to me getting out of depression.
Actually,
you as much as like you
were just like the butter,
like kind of guy.
You contributed a lot
into my healing process.
- [Woman] How do you feel?
- It's cool.
I like it.
- Yeah.
- It's cool.
(Men laugh)
I'm just like woo.
- It's definitely.
I don't, I don't usually
make myself vulnerable.
They know I'm very like
cutthroat and cold-hearted.
(Man laughs)
They all know, but yeah.
- You want to go first?
- Okay. My heart is beating 90 to nothing.
Yeah, okay.
Something I want to tell you is that
I wouldn't be who I am without you.
I'm feeling emotional.
You've made me come out of my shell
and push me to be a better person.
And I've always felt
really down around myself.
And you've always been
there to like pick me up
and give me that confidence.
And you were like a second dad to me.
Well first really.
I just, I wouldn't be me without you.
I, and, and if something
was to ever happen to you
I wouldn't ever be the same
because you're the most
important person in my life.
And I just love you so much.
(Woman laughs)
Sorry.
- That's okay.
You know, throughout my life,
you probably never told me
but you, you knew I was a hot mess
and partying all the time.
And like through all that
time, I was really depressed.
And it was because of you,
I started my career because of you.
You're the one who started it.
You're the reason now why I'm
getting as famous as I am now
is because of you, you started my career.
You made me, you helped me
find the passion that I need.
A job, something that I love so much.
And you know that I
care so much about you.
Because you know every time
I've ever done your hair,
it wasn't just doing hair.
It was, it was a conscious,
emotional connection between us
because you trusted me and I
trusted you all the time, so.
- I love you.
- I love you too.
- [Woman] Give him a hug.
(Man and Woman laugh)
(dramatic music)
- Quick announcement.
If you didn't know yet, I
recently launched my podcast.
It's called Hey stranger.
And if you like these videos
I think you might like my podcast as well.
So it means a lot if you gave it a chance
I'll have it linked into description.
So yeah, I'm really excited
to hear your thoughts on it.
And yeah, that's pretty much it.
Thank you guys for everything.
I love you all.
And I'll see you next week.